last week I heard that you were speaking
uh a lot about wives uh not wanting to
have sex with your husbands and I'm
experiencing the other way around I'm
married for two years but I actually
kind of lost interest in my wife we have
one children sorry one child
and yeah it's it's like
a um I'm not sure if this could be a
cause for me to start looking at uh some
options why did you lose interest in
your
wife um I don't know it it just it kind
of happened uh gradually there wasn't
just one thing
that she put on a load of
weight um not a lot maybe she gained it
uh around I don't know um 10 pounds or
something after giving birth to or
daughter yeah but uh no she's she's uh
she's not mean at all do you watch she's
very
lovely um
occasionally I couldn't say that I never
do it but uh I I don't think that it's a
problem for me well I mean porn's not
not good in general I mean how many
times a week you watch
porn
um one or two I think what four like why
not bang
instead ah perhaps that's that's the
reason I'm I'm just not not very
attracted uh to my wife anymore yeah
like you know porn's not real right like
it's it's it's acting there's it's not
real acting it's
acting yeah it yeah I know it it re it
rewires your brain there's lots of
YouTube videos there's even books and I
think there's hubman podcast interviews
where he's talked to specialist about
how porn affects the male brain it
rewires your brain and your expectations
right so it's not it's not good in
general um and also I mean you're
rubbing one out to another dude banging
another chick like you're basic it's
basically cuckoldry you know like I know
a guy that's a bull and women meet him
on dating apps and the husband sits in
the corner of the hotel room while he
watches this guy bang the wife right
that's essentially what you're doing but
you're looking at it on scream so from
that perspective it's cuckol
Tre so stop doing that for starters did
you have enthusiasm for her before you
got
married yes for sure like like strong
enthusiasm like like you craved her like
you lusted for her yes okay did she stop
doing a lot of the things that she used
to
do um like what well you know like women
will generally be more enthusiastic
early on than later on and Esther Perell
talks about this like women generally
lose interests in men faster than men do
in women like it's like a hockey stick
it goes like this over time whereas men
it's a little bit slower um and it's and
if a woman starts to lose enthusiasm for
you and she's not as um I I'm trying to
be careful here because you know we're
using YouTube on this um if she's not
doing all the things that she did at the
beginning today putting on the sexy
lingerie uh soaking wet like all of that
good stuff that you know would happen
early on like if that's on the decline
then that could be contributing to the
lack of interest that you have in her
too right like I would lose interest in
a check too like
that yes that makes sense also I think
it happens since we start living
together and perhaps I
IDE yeah yeah perhaps I I just had her
idealized in my mind and then I I don't
know I I just uh discovered something
that I didn't like about her and yeah
because you get familiar you get to know
her you get to know her little quirks
and features about her life she gets to
know yours the enthusiasm from one
another starts to go on the de like this
is this is part for the course with most
people that get married right um did she
ever initiate sex before you know like
before you got
married yes and she does now as well um
and uh okay um it it doesn't happen very
often but uh sometimes I also kind of
reject her because um I I also I'm
working a lot
lately so sometimes I'm just
tired yeah I mean but no guy is
generally that tired to turn down a
sexual advance from an attractive woman
the other thing that happens too bud is
that when you get married your
testosterone levels drop especially when
you have a kid it's it's they've they've
seen this over and over and over and
over again right in human studies and
they suspect it's because you go from
being a high te Hunter Warrior you know
banging as many chicks as you possibly
can to now you have a kid so you want to
protect and provide for that kid so
nature lowers testosterone levels so
that you're more interested in Protec
and providing and nurturing that child
you know your Offspring your DNA your
name your lineage you know so it's
successful so you might want to go to a
doctor and check your endocrine system
see if your testosterone levels your
free testosterone your
DHT your estradi like all of these
things are in healthy
ranges got it yeah that makes sense as
well perhaps it could be many factors
you could be pouring both uh my tea
levels
I I'm
31 it doesn't really start to go down
until
2530 so unless you've had a significant
change in lifestyle or maybe you just
like a bit of a anomaly and your tea
levels have dropped you know
dramatically for some reason um that
could be part of it do you wake up in
the morning with morning
wood um yes
okay so maybe it's not your tea levels
but it's worth checking out anyway you
might have deficiencies in other areas
in your blood Labs
right something else to consider but if
but if everything's healthy and she's
hitting on you and you're not interested
and you're interested elsewhere look
dude your option is to stay faithful and
suck it up and raise that kid and stay
married to her or you can have a
conversation with her and just say look
I love you I'm I love the family I love
you know our kid and I don't want to do
anything to ruin that or damage it but I
want to have some fun outside I want to
go and get some exercise elsewhere I'm
not going to do anything to embarrass
you I'm not going to bring home a
disease I'm not going to be falling in
love with anybody taking anybody on a
vacation I'm just going to go and get
some exercise you just need to know that
this is going to
happen the last thing you want to do is
lie to her and misrepresent something CU
that will have greater consequences than
being forthright about
it got it okay okay that that answered
my question and I think you point me in
the right direction all right but I
would start by going to a doctor and
getting getting your blood Labs check
and you know see if there's anything
weird going on there and stop touching
porn too po porn's just a huge waste of
time I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out